ils viennent à chalon tenir un meeting
commun pour soutenir
emmanuel macron côte à côte deux figures
régionales emblématique de la gauche et
de la droite gouvernementale
l'ancien président ps de la région et
l'ancien maire rpr de chalon une image
encore inconcevable il y a quelques mois
la situation politique de notre pays
a beaucoup changé elle est aujourd'hui
difficile je pense qu'il faut rassembler
les bonnes volontés et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis dans ce
rassemblement avec toutes celles et ceux
qui sont aussi et donc françois patriat
en particulier ce qui est nouveau c'est
de voir côte à côte deux hommes
politiques qui ont déjà une longue
carrière derrière eux incapables de
transcender les courants actuels pour
donner une autre politique de masse que
j'espère vous promener avec emmanuel
marron à l'intérieur deux cents
personnes venues d écouter ils viennent
de la gauche de la droite et du centre
cette alliance ne les choque pas au
contraire c'est même ce qui les séduit
je trouve ça bien sûr que ça va apporter
des idées de droite et de gauche qui
sont obligés dissipée à douche qui sont
bonnes des ide à droite qui sont bonnes
et c'est pour ça qu'ils manuel mata
enchaîne bien renouvellement de la
politique à renouvellement
c'est formidable à la tribune dominique
perben explique la lassitude des
français face à l'alternance
gauche-droite perçu comme stérile
il insiste sur la nécessité d'une base
du large pour réformer fort de ces
expériences ministérielles
il apporte son crédit aux candidats dans
marche pour assurer les pouvoirs
régaliens comme la sécurité ou la
justice françois patriat sur le terrain
économique par deux fonds candidats
comme le seul capable de voir le monde
tel qu'il est et non tel qu'il a été
moderne rassembleur crédibles les
qualités mises en avant ce soir
et dans la salle l'espoir de la victoire
car yannick on sent vraiment moi je veux
y croire en puissance il reste moins de
deux semaines aux marcheurs de droite
comme de gauche pour convaincre les
français que le candidat du renouveau
c'est emmanuel macron
emmanuel
et dans cette